[Music]
Latoya Jackson oh yes
I mean you connected with the King of
Pop Michael Jackson chill so surreal to
me when he came through we were so funny
because I was expecting him come with
you moonwalking but he didn't come
through that way at all he was very
private very very sweet and connecting
with his sister I just I'm here I love
you I'm around and it was very friendly
it wasn't like the Michael Jackson I
thought Tyler Henry detailing what it
was like to connect with the late
Michael Jackson during a reading with
his younger sister Latoya this reading
is being kept top secret no footage has
even been released but we have all the
exclusive details on the intimate
episode slated to air as this season's
finale can you describe the image
because I'm like you I'm picturing him
moonwalking what did he look like well
it's funny because I never saw a visual
depiction of him himself but he did
communicate some images so that I
thought were interesting and a lot of
them were very innocent and definitely
spoke to his inherent innocence I mean
his personality and he showed me a Dumbo
ride and it's all the Dumbo ears I'm
like and he had it on the ranch and the
toy validated this and that was one of
his favorite rides were you familiar
with anything about the ranch I knew
that there had been like it was a place
where the Boyd had fun and he had things
there but I didn't know anything about
the Dumbo thing what types of questions
did she have for you there were still
some details about his passing that she
was unresolved about so by him coming
through and delivering a message of who
was around who wasn't and how that
happened in a chronological order I
think really helped her put it to rest
so when you connect with a spirit is it
I'm Michael Jackson right before he
passes is it sort of a spirit that
inhibits his younger body great question
you know I find every single person
that's came through and over a thousand
readings has acknowledged being a more
enlightened version of themselves and
when he came through he came through
with a deep understanding of his life
how that affected others how others
affected him didn't come through with
any anger and resentment - he came
across with a lot of love much like a
child and it was really beautiful
Taylor says MJ also had messages for his
kids there were some references that he
made towards his children that very
specific how do you think his kids
Paris and blanket and prints are gonna
receive the episode I hope they receive
it well you know I think it clearly
comes from a place of love and good
and I think that they'll definitely be
able to get something out of it and the
message is there's a personal in
specific that I think obviously made
sense to Latoya a lot will make sense to
them and I hope that she's passed on
some of the messages - were they
emotional messages it's actually makes
her personal validations things that he
had seen and witnessed them doing since
as well as just personal stuff and he's
very very connected to his daughter he
definitely was again it was real real
real personal yeah I was deeply personal
didn't Latoya cry at all what she
emotion she was at a point but what was
so fun is that she was actually really
uplifted by the experience it's
sometimes even laughter so did he say
anything about music or his legacy there
absolutely were some things that were
reference to you up to the episode of
potential crossover with music thing at
least with another artist to past you'll
happen do you have to give me eyes lower
than that you have to watch the officer
his fans will be happy you thing I
definitely think his fans will have an
opportunity to have a deeper
understanding of what happened in detail
and just understand that he's at peace
is still with his family and that how he
passed away it doesn't define his life
we are so much more than the transitions
we make
[Music]